[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de Parlement Hebdo la
semaine parlementaire sous le regard de
notre invité et on accueille cette
semaine Sandrine Rousseau député
écologiste de Paris bonjour bonjour la
question du maintien de l'ordre est donc
à la une avec des échanges aux vitriol à
l'Assemblée comme au Sénat dans un
contexte social tendu et de violence à
Sainte Soline Gérald Darmanin qui sera
auditionné devant les députés
la contestation sociale ne faiblit pas
les syndicats sont invités à Matignon la
semaine prochaine alors qu'une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation est prévue et
puis le sujet de la fin de vie était à
l'ordre du jour les députés ont rendu
leur évaluation de la loi kless Leonetti
un bilan n'est pas encore de proposition
pour une aide active à mourir et avant
d'évoquer tous ces sujets retours sur le
plan de gestion de l'eau qui a été
présenté jeudi par le Président de la
République Emmanuel Macron annonce des
mesures de sobriété pour tous les
secteurs de l'économie on l'écoute comme
là aussi nous l'avons fait pour
l'énergie nous allons demander à chaque
secteur un plan de sobriété sur l'eau
d'ici à l'été les ministres réuniront
dans les prochains jours dans l'ensemble
des secteurs concernés l'énergie
l'industrie le tourisme les loisirs
l'agriculture ça marche bien quand tout
le monde sait l'évolution de la
situation quand tout le monde est
responsabilisé et quand on sait que les
efforts sont partagés
Sandrine Rousseau est-ce que vous êtes
convaincu par ce plan de sobriété dans
l'usage de l'eau qui a été présenté par
le Président de la République non pas du
tout alors déjà que Emmanuel Macron se
rend compte qu'on a besoin de se briété
dans tact et donner en lui ce bon point
après il parle quand même d'un plan de
l'eau en évitant l'éléphant qui est dans
le couloir qui s'appelle les méga
bassines et mes rétentions d'eau pour
l'agriculture les stations de ski et les
retenues colinéaires enfin tout ce qui
est appropriation de l'eau donc en fait
on est toujours dans la même dans la
même optique pour Emmanuel Macron c'est
à dire ce sont des efforts qui sont
individuels les individus sont rendus
responsables d'une partie et puis de
l'autre un impensé sur le partage sur le
bien commun sur ce que peut-être une
ressource naturelle et quel est son
statut et en fait je crois que
finalement c'est le débat qui nous
manque c'est comment fait-on pour
entamer cette transformation écologique
et bien ça nécessite de revoir notre
rapport à la nature notre rapport assez
bien commun et de leur donner un statut
de commun et là c'est ce qui manque dans
ce dans ce alors il propose en tout cas
il nous met le tarification de l'eau
pour inciter à des usages plus
responsables pour vous c'est une bonne
méthode ou pas oui ça c'est bien d'avoir
une tarification progressive de l'eau
après est-ce que ça s'appliquera aux
agriculteurs par exemple et est-ce que
ça s'appliquera au retenu colinéaires et
aux gabassine ou est-ce que c'est ce
sera considéré comme de l'eau de pluie
et donc ça ne rentrera pas dans la
tarification progressive c'est ça qu'il
faut voir c'est si ça ne s'adresse
qu'aux particuliers alors sa rate sa
cible ce qu'elle voulait montrer aussi
le président de la République c'est que
le pays peut continuer à avancer sur des
sujets importants malgré la contestation
sociale actuelle oui alors ça c'est pas
la première fois qui s'empare de
l'écologie comme d'une espèce de cerise
qui met sur un gâteau après une
contestation sociale on l'avait vu après
les gilets jaunes où il y avait eu cette
je crois que la convention pour le
climat était juste après les gilets
jaunes et il avait fait comme ça en
disant qu'il allait prendre en compte
les questions écologiques à cette année
que stratégie que je pense que
l'utilisation de l'écologie dans la
manière d'être politique d'Emmanuel
Macron et dans ses actions n'est que
stratégique et n'est qu'opportuniste en
fait et puis derrière surtout en même
temps on apprend parce que je crois que
c'est exactement on met enfin au même
moment qu'on apprend que le ministre de
l'Agriculture hésite à relancer et à
réautoriser des pesticides qui sont
extrêmement dangereux pour la santé
c'est au même moment que dans au
Parlement la majorité Renaissance refuse
de d'interdire les nitrites dans les
jambons dans les jambons cuits notamment
qui sont adressés aux enfants dans les
cantines enfin vous voyez c'est vraiment
c'est du théâtre d'écologie
sociale actuelle et notamment de la
question du maintien de l'ordre après
les violences à sainte-solines autour
des projets de méga bassines après les
violences en marche des manifestations
contre la réforme des retraites la
gauche du Sénat estime que la stratégie
policière n'est pas la bonne et demande
des comptes au ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin les explications de
Fabien Ricard
200 blessés parmi les manifestants 47
parmi les gendarmes le bilan humain de
la manifestation de sainte Soline
interroge quant à la stratégie du
maintien de l'ordre des autorités
mercredi au Sénat la gauche a attaqué
frontalement le ministre de l'Intérieur
le bilan de ce qu'il s'est passé samedi
à Sainte-Soline est lourd je le sais j'y
étais
et je l'assume vous avez décidé à Sainte
Soline d'exposer 3000 forces de l'ordre
à la violence dans un champ pour
défendre quoi qu'il en coûte un trou un
trou vide je regrette que des
parlementaires revendique d'aller dans
une manifestation illégale
Gérald Darmanin ni en bloc les
accusations faites aux forces de l'ordre
d'avoir empêché les secours d'intervenir
des accusations étayées par un
enregistrement que s'est procuré le
journal Le Monde une enquête judiciaire
est ouverte le ministre n'en est pas
moins applaudi par la droite sénatoriale
qui ne veut pas entendre parler de
violences policières qui imaginent dans
ce pays que des gendarmes que des
policiers que des militaires d'ailleurs
parfois pour les missions de service
public avec bonheur ce délecte d'aller
massacrer manifestants bien entendu que
ça n'existe pas en vrai quand vous
recevez des pluies de projectiles de la
part des manifestants vous avez des
réactions la polémique autour de sainte
Soline intervient en pleine mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites
récemment montées d'un cran dans la
violence dans le viseur des oppositions
de gauche les interventions de la braven
la brigade de répression de l'action
violente les faits commis par la brave
la semaine dernière à Paris sont
inacceptables
Valentin 19 ans je je me suis projeté au
sol une moto me roule sur la jambe
gauche hématome de 56 cm
Soulayman 23 ans tu as tellement de
chance d'être assis là je te jure je te
pétais les jambes au sens propre je peux
te dire qu'on en a cassé des coudes et
des gueules je serai jamais dans la
démagogie comme vous l'êtes madame la
sénatrice qui consiste à comparer de
manière équitable les violences de la
police je mets des guillemets des
violences des casseurs le ministre de
l'intérieur doit être auditionné la
semaine prochaine par la commission des
lois de l'Assemblée nationale sur la
question du maintien de l'ordre voilà
pour ce sujet de Fabien reker et de
mathiasarez Sandrine Rousseau qu'est-ce
que vous attendez de l'audition mercredi
prochain du ministre de l'Intérieur à
l'Assemblée nationale sur ce sujet avant
de vous dire ce que j'attends de cette
audition et je voudrais dire que il y a
quelque chose qui devient vraiment très
difficile à supporter et pour moi et je
pense pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens
et concitoyennes c'est l'espèce de ton
condescendant avec lesquels les
ministres s'adressent à nous s'adresse à
la représentation parlementaire mais
s'adresse aussi au peuple et vraiment
l'entretien d'Emmanuel Macron à 13h
avait cette espèce de ton cette espèce
d'outrance qui ne s'y est pas un chef
d'État et là la manière dont le ministre
de l'Intérieur réponde ne s'y est pas à
quelqu'un qui a émont témoin menti qui a
mis ses forces de l'ordre en danger en
les mettant d'eau à la bassine et qui
refuse de reconnaître le changement de
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre tout le
monde tout le monde tous les organismes
internationaux que ce soit l'ONU la
Maison Blanche même
tout le monde dénonce la manière dont
l'ordre est maintenu en France et dont
les manifestations sont encadrées tout
le monde pourquoi nous devrions subir ça
nous sommes en démocratie nous sommes
censés être dans le pays des droits de
l'homme et là le monde entier critique
la manière dont les manifestations sont
encadrées et
et lui il arrive et il dit vous faites
de la démagogie c'est ça sa réponse mais
vraiment si nous étions un peuple qui
tenions encore beaucoup à notre
démocratie nous devrions nous lever là
nous devrions nous lever parce que ce
qui est en train de se passer est grave
alors justement il sera auditionné
devant la commission des lois de
l'Assemblée nationale Gérard dahmana
mardi mercredi pardon est-ce que vous
allez par ailleurs demander une
commission d'enquête vous groupe
écologiste vous n'avez pas encore
utilisé votre droit de tirage est-ce que
vous pourriez le faire sur les
événements de sainte Soline ou pas oui
nous pourrions le faire et moi je vais
défendre cette position au sein du
groupe écologiste dont je ne sais pas
encore quelle sera la décision je pense
que nous l'apprendrons mardi mais moi je
pousserai la position selon laquelle il
nous faut une commission d'enquête sur
la manière dont on est militants
écologiste sont traités et donc d'une
manière générale il y a une surveillance
on l'avait vu avec la cellule Demeter
qui était quand même une cellule de
renseignement dédiée aux militantisme
écologistes et on le voit à Bure aussi
avec la surveillance qu'il y a eu
incroyable des militants
[Musique]
cette non c'est un appel à la résistance
c'est un appel à la résistance parce que
il y a déjà eu des répressions violentes
sur les gilets jaunes et je rappelle
quand même que les gilets jaunes étaient
une révolte sociale au départ que ces
gens qui ont qui se sont mis et gilets
jaunes étaient beaucoup des personnes
qui ont été en première ligne pendant le
covid c'était les éboueurs c'était les
caissiers caissières c'était les chefs
de rayons c'était les personnels du soin
enfin c'était toutes ces professions là
et en fait à l'issue du covid on leur
dit bah vous allez travailler deux ans
de plus donc ils ont tout donné et on
leur dit vous allez travailler deux ans
plus et en fait cette séquence
répression première ligne et vous allez
donner deux ans de plus donne une espèce
de rage social et on ne réprime pas de
la rage social par de la violence
policière ou alors on se met dans un
chemin qui vraiment je pense c'est
dangereux à terme donc là il nous faut
non seulement apaiser mais aussi trouver
les moyens de reconnaître que de la
parole qui s'exprime dans la rue est une
parole légitime Darmanin estime lui que
la nupaisse un problème il le dit avec
la police de la République est-ce que
c'est le cas est-ce que la police pour
vous n'est pas républicaine je pense que
Gérald Darmanin a un problème avec le
respect des droits humains fondamentaux
et avec le fait que les policiers sont
en charge du maintien de la paix du
maintien de la paix et que ça n'est pas
parce que la police a la monopole de la
violence légitime même si on pourrait
contester ça sur le plan philosophique
etc mais je vais pas rentrer dans ces
débats là mais la police disons-le à le
monopole de la violence légitime de
l'État précisément parce qu'elle l'a
parce qu'elle l'a elle a la
responsabilité de ne pas l'utiliser et
c'est cela que Gérald Darmanin ne
comprend pas et vraiment nous ne nous
sortons pas grandit de la manière dont
on est dans les manifestations ont été
réprimés une question une dernière
question rapide sur ce sujet est-ce que
vous pensez que la brave m les brigades
mobiles peuvent être dissoutes notamment
après la pétition à l'Assemblée
nationale qui a déjà recueilli 100 000
signatures ce texte peut aboutir alors
il faut qu'elle soit dissoute surtout
que il a été prévu dans le cadre de
l'encadrement des Jeux Olympiques que on
passe de 92 équipes de braves m à 135 je
crois de mémoire et donc
qu'on augmente de près de 50 % la le
nombre d'équipage de la braven ça c'est
vraiment une brigade qui n'est faite que
pour une chose c'est semer la terreur se
met la terreur et ça n'est pas
admissible ça n'est pas admissible
vraiment vraiment et là enfin je sais
pas comment le dire mais Gérald Darmanin
doit démissionner nous devons changer de
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre et je
rappelle que des révolutions comme mai
68 on n'ont pas connu de mort là nous
avons deux personnes qui sont entre la
vie et la mort et dont le pronostic
vital est toujours engagé enfin vraiment
vraiment là nous nous n'avons pas le
droit de faire ça vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens et concitoyens quoi qu'il se
passe quoi qu'il se passe nous avons pas
le droit de faire ça alors le sujet des
retraites sans notreceau est toujours
bien évidemment à la Une les syndicats
appellent à une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation la semaine prochaine tandis
que Elisabeth borde les invite à
Matignon la première ministre qui devant
les sénateurs a appelé au dialogue
écoutez
depuis lundi j'ai donc entamé une série
de consultations j'ai vu hier le
président du Sénat et la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale je l'ai poursuit
avec les forces politiques les
parlementaires les élus locaux et les
partenaires sociaux que j'ai invités à
une rencontre en début de semaine
prochaine mais seul ambition c'est de
trouver des solutions au service des
Français et de bâtir des majorités de
projets pour les mettre en œuvre toutes
celles et ceux qui veulent agir pour les
Français sont les bienvenus c'est de
cette manière par la concertation par le
dialogue et par le compromis que nous
répondons répondrons aux inquiétudes de
nos compatriotes
sandre Rousseau est-ce que cette
rencontre prévue à Matignon peut selon
vous débloquer la situation vous dites
enfin ou trop tard
bien trop tard mais enfin
bien trop tard on a eu quand même des
semaines et des semaines de
manifestation et il n'y a pas eu la
moindre invité invitation à se rendre à
Matignon quelle est cette première
ministre quelle est cette première
ministre qui ne reconnaît pas les
syndicats alors que les syndicats je le
rappelle pour être représentatifs sont
élus donc ils ont une légitimité à
porter la contestation sociale et à
représenter les salariés et bien c'est
la question et c'est pour ça que moi je
pense que enfin voilà nous les groupes
politiques n'allons pas y aller parce
que nous naissons les syndicats y aller
en premier et que je pense que c'est
respectueux du combat incroyable qu'on
menait les syndicats ces dernières
semaines mais moi j'aurais vraiment aimé
qu'on le serait pas non nous n'y seront
pas nous n'y seront pas parce que c'est
au syndicat d'être entendu en premier
parce que c'est leur mouvement et que ça
se respecte et que nous nous sommes en
arrière-plan de ce mouvement nous
relayons ce mouvement mais nous n'en
sommes pas au premier plan mais moi
j'aurais aimé vraiment rentrer dans
Matignon et lui demander de démissionner
j'aurais aimé le faire avec son
gouvernement je l'ai dit pour Gérald
Darmanin parce que toute la désastreuses
pour pour eux et en l'occurrence avoir
un conflit social de cette ampleur là
historique de plusieurs semaines et ne
pas tendre la main une seule fois une
seule fois au syndicat ça n'est pas
raisonnable ça n'est pas raisonnable et
ça met la France à feu et à 100 tout ça
pour 10 milliards d'euros d'économies
tout ça pour un modèle productiviste
tout ça pour quelque chose qui
finalement ne fait qu'aggraver les
problèmes dans lesquels nous sommes qui
sont le réchauffement climatique et la
crise sociale où sommes-nous quand
est-ce qu'on prend en compte le bien
commun au nom de quoi fait-on les
politiques publiques alors vous le
disiez les parlementaires de gauche
refusent cet entretien avec la première
ministre à Matignon et ils appellent
plutôt et bien à marcher jusqu'à
l'Elysée mardi quel est le but de cette
marche vers l'Elysée c'est de mettre
encore plus la pression sur le président
de la République c'est de dire que
Emmanuel Macron est le grand ordonnateur
de cette séquence et que il ne va pas se
défausser de ses responsabilités parce
qu'on voit et ça c'est aussi un des
traits de sans doute de caractère
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est que dès que la
situation devient un peu compliqué et
bien il accuse sa première ministre et
il a même je crois utilisé ce mot de
stupide qui me semble quand même devoir
être interrogé en démocratie quand un
président de la République traite ainsi
sa première ministre mais c'est lui qui
est responsable de cette séquence il en
a fait vraiment une affaire presque
presque personnelle
identitaire en tous les cas de son
mandat de faire cette réforme des
retraites il a même dit que ce second
mandat ne débuterait qu'à partir du
moment où cette réforme des retraites
aurait été faite et donc
c'est lui le responsable cette séquence
et c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il est
important aussi de se positionner
vis-à-vis d'Emmanuel Macron en leur
disant nous ne sommes pas du tout en lui
disant pardon nous ne sommes pas dupe et
nous serons là et nous savons que c'est
vous qui soufflez sur les braises d'une
France qui va mal et vous allez tous
marcher vers l'Elysée y compris avec les
Français à ce jour-là devrait être dans
la rue vous les appelez à ce jour j'ai
pas encore discuté avec les autres
groupes politiques mais peut-être
pourquoi pas ce serait bien que les
Français manifestent devant l'Élysée
selon vous je pense le lien en rapport
de force directe à instaurer avec le
président de la République oui petite
question très rapide dans deux semaines
exactement le Conseil constitutionnel
rendra sa décision très attendue sur la
réforme des retraites si le texte devait
être validé est-ce que pour vous ça peut
étendre la mobilisation alors pour le
coup j'ai sans doute me différencier des
autres des autres représentants
politiques c'est que moi je ne n'attends
rien de ce Conseil constitutionnel je ne
pense pas qu'elle a Juppé
être sur une position qui rejoint et les
manifestants et la nuit pèse je ne suis
pas complètement sûr que les Avengers du
Conseil constitutionnel qui en je pense
en plus une moyenne d'âge qui fait que
ils sont peu concernés par les questions
d'âge de départ en retraite vont nous
sauver de cette crise sociale donc voilà
je le dis parce que je pense que il faut
pas non plus installer une séquence qui
dirait ah bah si le Conseil
constitutionnel la valider c'est que
c'est bon non ça n'est toujours pas bon
non ça n'est toujours pas bon et après
il y aura le référendum d'initiative
partagé et puis de toute façon il y aura
la continuité de cette mobilisation et
enfin moi j'ai envie vraiment et
Emmanuel Macron et Elisabeth borne a
entendre que sur l'âge il faut revenir
en arrière on va parler d'un autre sujet
Sandrine Rousseau une question sensible
celle de la fin de vie qui était à
l'ordre du jour des députés la mission
d'évaluation de la loi classique
Léonetti sur la fin de vie a présenté
ses conclusions à l'Assemblée nationale
regardez ce sujet d'Elsa monte
de vie prochain débat de société à
l'Assemblée nationale une mission
d'évaluation s'est penchée sur la loi
klace Leonetti votée il y a 7 ans le
constat c'est tout d'abord celui d'une
offre insuffisante de soins palliatifs
fin 2021 21 départements on était
dépourvus dans son rapport la mission
pointe également une méconnaissance du
dispositif des directives anticipés et
de la personne de confiance sans en
préjugé les raisons les députés
s'interrogent sur une utilisation
très limité de la sédation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès pour autant il
ne se positionne pas dans leur rapport
pour ou contre une aide active à mourir
vous voyez le
l'exercice délicat puisque nous n'avions
pas vocation à proposer une nouvelle loi
sur les actives à mourir mais de faire
en sorte d'améliorer autant que possible
dans les pratiques et dans le vécu des
malades de faire en sorte que nous
n'ayons pas les situations que nous
avons pu constater ce qui ne veut pas
dire
[Musique]
un manque de nourriture et d'eau et que
moi je ne veux pas mourir comme ça par
exemple et
profonde continue jusqu'à la mort
c'est-à-dire en clair on
Réclère on met de la morphine on est des
sédatifs et mais on a on arrête
l'alimentation et l'hydratation et en
fait moi je ne veux pas mourir comme ça
je veux mourir dignement je veux je veux
choisir le moment de ma mort et je pense
que nous sommes nombreux et nombreuses
et que en fait ça n'enlève aucun droit à
ceux qui ne veulent pas si à ceux qui
veulent mourir j'ai envie de dire par
sédation profonde ou de manière
totalement naturelle sans aucune aide et
bien ils pourront toujours le faire mais
pour celles et ceux qui ne le veulent
pas et bien ils ont ils devraient aussi
avoir le droit de choisir et moi
l'expérience personnelle à laquelle vous
faites référencer celle de ma maman
que j'ai accompagné dans sa fin de vie
qui s'est suicidé parce que précisément
elle n'avait pas accès à une fin de vie
digne et en fait au nom de quoi alors
que les gens se sont battus souvent de
manière très courageuse dans des
maladies longues qui les ont fait
souffrir de mines et une manières au nom
de quoi leur impose ton ces ultime
souffrance et aujourd'hui je n'ai
toujours pas la réponse donc oui je
continuerai à me battre c'est une
promesse que je lui ai fait pour le coup
sur le son nid de mort et je continuerai
à me battre jusqu'à mon dernier souffle
pour que nous ayons le droit de mourir
autrement et alors selon vous comment
faut-il changer la loi est-ce qu'il faut
légaliser le tanasie ou le suicide
assisté ou proposer les deux options je
pense qu'il faut proposer les deux
options et je pense que il faut aussi
des structures qui permettent de mettre
en oeuvre ces deux options parce que un
des sujets c'est est-ce qu'on le fait à
l'hôpital est-ce qu'on le fait et
là-dessus avoir des lieux qui soient des
lieux prévus pour cela où il y ait une
forme de douceur aussi et de de un lieu
d'amour à ses proches pour pouvoir leur
dire combien ils ont été combien ces
personnes ont été heureuses de
rencontrer les proches les personnes
qu'elles aimaient etc un lieu paisible
un lieu serein et bien je pense que ce
serait vraiment de nature à apaiser bien
des relations familiales par ailleurs et
à permettre à des gens d'être fier aussi
de ce qu'ils ont vécu et de dire au
revoir fièrement à ceux qui le sont
aimés vous pensez qu'une loi peut être
votée notamment dans cette période sur
la fin de vie au Parlement je pense
qu'Emmanuel Macron a toujours
reculé sur les aspects de progrès
sociétaux pour ceux qui a peur je pense
qu'il a peur mais je pense qu'il a peur
de tout sauf des marchés financiers ce
qui est un problème d'ailleurs mais je
pense qu'il a peur oui
on va finir cette émission en regardant
et bien ce qu'il y a la semaine
prochaine à l'agenda du Parlement
[Musique]
et mercredi au Sénat les sénateurs vont
examiner une proposition de loi pour
renforcer la parité dans la fonction
publique jeudi ce sera l'examen d'une
proposition de loi sur la
renationalisation de DF et on l'a dit à
l'Assemblée mercredi 5 mars l'audition
de Gérard Darmanin devant la commission
des lois et je dis journée réservé à
votre groupe groupe écologie Sandrine
Rousseau avec 8 textes examinés en tout
cas c'est alors du jour dont la vôtre
une proposition de de loi qui vise à
mieux indemniser les victimes dans les
maisons subissent des des fissures
importantes ou des dégâts en raison du
phénomène qu'on appelle le retrait et le
gonflement de de l'argile en fait c'est
du c'est l'une des conséquences de la
sécheresse si je puis résumer très
brièvement juste une petite question
est-ce que vous aurez les voix pour
faire voter cette proposition de loi
jeudi et ce qu'elle sera déjà examinée
qui a beaucoup de textes non seulement
elle sera examiné mais en plus elle est
passée en commission des finances et
elle a été votée adoptée à l'unanimité
parce qu'il n'y a pas eu de voie contre
il y a eu des abstentions mais il n'y a
pas eu de voix contre et donc
du groupe Renaissance et donc j'ai très
bon espoir qu'elle puisse être adoptée
en hémicycle et je pense que ce serait
un soulagement énorme pour bien de nos
concitoyens et concitoyennes et vraiment
je pense à vous à vous qui vivez dans
ces maisons fissurées je sais combien
vous êtes abandonnés et là la
représentation nationale je pense va
vous entendre et vous la porterez donc
je dis des 9h du matin ce sera la
première non ce sera pas la première
mais ça sera dans la journée est-ce que
vous avez des informations sur le coup
que ça représenterait cette
indemnisation des personnes touchées en
train de faire les évaluations mais je
voudrais dire que ça ne se pose pas pour
moi en termes de coup il y a ce sont des
vies des gens et ces maisons ont été
achetées souvent au prix de très grands
sacrifices des personnes qui ne sont pas
partis en vacances qui ont mis beaucoup
de leur vie et de leurs heures
travaillées dans ces
maisons et moins d'une sur deux est
aujourd'hui indemnisée ce qui n'est pas
normal et c'est la fin de cette émission
merci beaucoup Sandrine Rousseau d'avoir
été l'invité de Parlement Hebdo à cette
semaine et merci à tous de l'avoir suivi
et on se retrouve
la Ciao
[Musique]